he moved to Indiana University in 1989
where he obtained his PhD in philosophy
and cognitive science working for the
legendary Douglas hofstadter by the way
I've got his book here in the center for
research on Concepts and cognition and
Douglas by the way is one of the most
legendary figures in the AI space we
also had the pleasure of interviewing
one of his other PhD students Professor
Melanie Mitchell now David recently
wrote this fascinating book called
reality Plus
and in that book he discussed the three
Central philosophical questions actually
uh the reality question which is to say
are Virtual Worlds real his answer to
that is yes the knowledge question which
is to say can we know whether or not
we're in a virtual world his answer to
that is no and also
um the value question which is to say
can you lead a good life in a virtual
world and his answer to that is a
resounding yes now you've probably also
heard of this notion of an extended mind
something which David formulated with
Professor Andy Clark and they described
the idea as active externalism based on
the active role of the environment in
driving cognitive processes or put
simply you might think of your phone as
being an extension of your mind for
example what was it like to work with
Douglas during your PhD oh he was great
he was so
he is interested in uh in so many things
um you know it was officially it was a
it was an AI lab and most of the people
there were uh were AI researchers you
mentioned Melanie Mitchell she was my
colleague there uh Bob French who's done
important work on AI Gary McGraw
uh Jim Marshall wongpei and others
I was the only philosopher people were
interested in so many things whether it
was uh we had workshops on humor or
creativity
on um
on mathematics on Politics on everything
as well as all this stuff on AI analogy
Concepts it was also a very exciting
time to be there because this was one of
the um
you know this was the uh at least one of
the uh in the blumen bust cycle of
machine learning and of neural networks
this was one of the boom periods the
early 1990s uh the PDP books had just
come out parallel distributed processing
by bromel heart McClelland and Hinton
and there was so much uh excitement
about the capacities of neural networks
so I ended up doing
uh writing a few papers on machine
learning back then one was on the
evolution of learning systems one was on
getting machines to learn structural
generalizations and so in all with you
know fairly basic
neural networks
um I mean a few years after that you
know the bottom fell out of neural
networks for another 15 years or so but
this but this was a very exciting period
to be there one thing about dog that you
don't quite get from his books
um
in his books he's so enthusiastic about
everything
you know he's not into all these ideas
and so on but it turns out there's five
percent of things in the world or one
percent that he's enthusiastic about the
other 99 he hates
he's like he'd like certain very certain
certain approaches to AI he loved but uh
even neural networks he was like yeah he
was uh he was not a big fan of most of
most research on in a in a neural
networked back then he said I think it
was a this is a bandwagon or even he
said a bad wagon likewise for philosophy
that's a philosophy alarms there's a lot
of it uh there's a lot of it he doesn't
like so um maybe in person you get more
of a more of that very opinionated side
but really he's a
he's just you know that book go to Le
she bark was just I mean it was what
drew me into philosophy and AI as a
teenager and it's so rich and you go
back to that book there's still so many
ideas there the mind's eye is another
book he edited with Dan Dennett it was
reading the Bible that really first got
me thinking about issues about
Consciousness and the mind-body problem
so yeah he's a very rich thinker yeah
but thank God for Douglas tough starter
yeah I love the mines I has one of the
one of the eeriest stories of all um
what was it the riddle of the universe
and its solution where there's there's
some image or some text that if you read
it it causes your brain basically to
core dump and so it becomes this
infectious thing where anybody who goes
into that office and reads that thing
they just crash and they never they go
into a coma and they never wake up again
and so you know there's a huge
investigation to figure out what's going
on and more and more people keep going
into Comas you know because of this
crazy ideas in that book
could I just pick up on this point
because you you were saying that um
Douglas hofstatter
um turned his nose up at neural networks
and I hope he still would actually and
Melanie Mitchell certainly does and I
mean Douglas had that paper out called
the core of cognition he was always huge
about this idea of the Primacy of
analogy making and actually there's a
few researchers today that are that are
mirroring that that idea that Francois
Chalet for example he says intelligence
is literally sensitivity to abstract
analogies it's not memorizing the
internet so I think thank God that we do
have people out there thinking slightly
differently because the the modus
operandi today is is that we need to
build a big hash table of everything and
even the way we formalize intelligence
as we were just saying previously
we're not really paying attention to why
or how the things do what they do we're
just looking at the behavioral output
bit like the Turing test as long as it
looks and smells like a duck then it
must be a duck so so thank God for
Douglas hofstadter
yeah
um I think you know he's always been at
the same time and Enthusiast about the
possibility of AI while being somewhat
skeptical about the capacities of
existing
Ai and about the you know the kind of
hype that suggests that AI might just be
10 or 20 years around the corners so in
the early 90s I think yeah that was uh
that was especially especially natural
background then people would say a year
spent working in AI is enough to make
you believe in God
it was so hard to get anything even like
uh
any kind of intelligence out of it AI
system and I think you know Doug was
equally skeptical of both the symbolic
and the connectionist or neural network
approaches back then
um I think ultimately his sympathies
late with the on the neural network side
of things with the idea that
intelligence could in principle Bubble
Up from a million you know from 100
billion separate little interactions
intelligence could bubble up from there
but I still think he'd be inclined to
think that current approaches are too
statistical too simple and so on that
said you have to look at the uh at the
progress in machine learning over the
last
10 years and it's been amazing and
surprising and I think even somebody
like uh even people like Melanie or like
Doug are going to have to say this has
been something they did not expect and
that they did not predict so actually I
was back in Indiana just over two years
ago just before the the pandemic got
going February 2020 and
I don't know maybe that was before gbt3
but still they've been all these amazing
um developments
um in machine learning over the last few
years I asked Doug about this and what
what do you make of this and because you
know he's on the record of saying yeah
there will be AI eventually but it's
going to have to be involve all these
new kinds of complexity not not
something simple like this and he says
yeah well this is this is troubling this
is concerning you know it could be I
don't know yet but it could be that I
was wrong it could be there are simpler
passes paths to AI his attitude was that
would be very disappointing if it turned
out that you could actually you know
train up an AGI just using those those
simple methods to human levels that
would make I think Doug's viewers that
would make kind of human level
intelligence less
less Grand and remarkable than uh than
he had thought well actually back in
back in good Alicia bark I think he said
that even to have a machine that could
beat a human at chess
it would have to be good at everything
it would be a good composer it could
tell jokes
that one that view got rolled out back
in the uh back in the 90s so the
question is you know is this
is this ever growing progress of yeah
just of the kind of machine learning
that says just throw a whole lot of
compute and a whole lot of data at it
and see what happens is that eventually
going to get us to human level
intelligence or is it is it just going
to get us so far
with uh and there's going to be
principal limitations I've always been
on the side of
it'll probably only get us so far but I
have to say those
principled limitations those obstacles
that have not yet been uh conquered are
getting smaller and smaller and the
progress if the progress over the last
five or ten years continues for another
five or ten years then who's to say
what's going to be left
yeah that was a fascinating anecdote in
in Melanie's book about how she and
hofstata went to the Googleplex one time
then basically as you said Douglas was
terrified that intelligence might be
disappointingly simple to mechanize
because he he felt of the mind of Chopin
as being infinitely nuanced and uh just
just the incredible process that must
have gone through his mind when he when
he produced his music but
um I wanted to and just quickly by the
way you said that um there was a
conception in in the 70s that task
specific skill was what was required for
intelligence or a collection of specific
skills and and now the the the mindset
is much more towards task acquisition
efficiency and generalization but I
wanted to just quickly pick you up on um
the so-called intelligence explosion
question so this is a subject which Nick
Bostrom has popularized after his book
super intelligence personally speaking
we're not particularly sympathetic to
this View and uh cyber Francois late and
he said in a blog post recently that
this line of reasoning represents sense
a misunderstanding of intelligence he
said that in his opinion intelligence is
situational
he said that our environment puts a hard
limit on our individual intelligences he
said that most of our intelligence is
not in the brain it's externalized as
civilization and that an individual
brain cannot Implement recursive
intelligence augmentation like a god or
machine he also said that there are
already many examples of recursively
self-improving systems even personal
Investing For example is a recursively
self-improving system the more money you
have the more money you make
um anyway so Bostrom described a thought
experiment in 2003 I'm sure you've heard
of this the scenario describes an
artificial you know like a very Advanced
artificial intelligence task with
manufacturing paper clips if such a
machine were not programmed to Value
human life then given enough power over
its environment it would try to turn all
the matter in the universe including
human beings into paper clips or
machines which could manufacture paper
clips do you think we might be on the
precipice of being turned into paper
clips as Boston famously described in
his thought experiment
yeah look it's there's two different
issues here one is will we get to some
kind of much greater than
human super intelligence relatively soon
by some kind of intelligence explosion
process and second if that happens are
there major dangers around yeah I wrote
about both these things back in
2009 I had an article called uh yeah the
singularity of philosophical analysis
where I tried to take this line of
reasoning
foreign intelligence explosion through
recursive
um through basically through recursive
design of ever more sophisticated AIS I
tried to take that and turn it into an
argument I mean the classic statement of
this comes from IJ good the uh the
statistician and philosopher back in
1965 on the design of an ultra
intelligent machine where it puts the
basic idea right there that you know
once you've got a machine which is
smarter than a human
it will be able to design a machine
which is smarter still and then you're
going to get a recursive runaway
explosion of intelligence I've tried to
analyze that up to set out that article
that argument in as much detail as I
could analyze where it could go right
where it could go wrong what the
possible obstacles would be and it's a
long story this if anyone wants to look
it up it's uh it's out there
on my website but I in the M became
convinced this is a pretty powerful
argument there's only so many ways it
could go wrong
um I think it's important that not every
recursive augmentation process is going
to lead to an intelligence explosion it
could easily bottom out could asymptote
before human intelligence but I do think
that once we start from greater than
human intelligence we have to find some
way to get the greater than human
intelligence first this act this
explosion won't get you that but once
you get there
and there's pretty good reason to think
things uh in principle can take off from
there if uh intelligence is extended I'm
a big fan of the idea that intelligence
is extended into the environment but as
far as I can tell
um all that can in principle be
augmented too we develop extended
systems which are smarter than humans
and they can uh then they'll be they'll
be able to design even better extended
systems and we still get a we could then
have a intelligence explosion of intent
extended intelligences so I'm actually
nothing about this gets you to human
level intelligence but once we get to
human level intelligence and a little
bit beyond
then I think there's a pretty good case
that there's some kind of potential
explosion in the offing then the other
issue you mentioned Bostrom and the uh
the paper clips is yeah what does this
mean for the future of humanity I guess
I don't know what I'd say about the
probabilities but I'd say yeah there's
once you have greater than human
artificial general intelligence then
there's many ways that can go wrong for
the obvious reasons that yeah such a
being is going to be extremely extremely
powerful the most intelligent beings in
the universe tend to be the most
powerful for obvious reasons whatever
they want they have the they have the
capacity to get so it's going to be
extremely important that our
AGI systems want the right things that
is they have the right kind of goals or
as people put it these days that they
are aligned with uh with human goals
um because if they're
if they're even a little bit misaligned
then there's going to be the capacity
for things to go very badly wrong I know
there are some people who think that the
alignment is going to have to be so
precise that you know missed by just the
tiniest bit and we'll we'll destroy the
universe whereas others think it's uh
it's extremely robust
uh it may be more robust than that I'm
not totally sure about that but I'm
certainly on the side of people who
think we have to take this issue
extremely seriously and there is at
least potential existential risks here
that if AGI is produced in an unthinking
way perhaps say in a military or a
financial context where there's a AI
arms race
um and you suddenly and we suddenly have
um greater than human AIS that can that
can achieve arbitrary goals then yeah
suddenly it becomes an extremely
sensitive matter what their uh what
their goals are so I'm certainly on
postroom side when it comes to yeah this
is something we should take seriously
but isn't there a bit of uh you know
it's a big distance to go from
Superior to human intelligence and
achieve anything you want I mean I'm
relatively intelligent but I can't I
can't achieve flight you know by myself
without without you know apparatus to do
that in Airplane Wings whatever I mean
there are physical limitations in the
world and I think sometimes there's this
assumption that intelligence can kind of
go to Infinity where in fact maybe
intelligence itself kind of bottoms out
at IQ 1000 or something there's just not
much you know you can do beyond that
certain IQ I mean isn't there a degree
of of kind of a speculative uh you know
extrapolation that we're that we need to
account for there
I would say this is certainly one way
that things could that the argument
could fail is if it turns out that
basically there are diminishing there's
some kind of intelligent ceiling and
there's some kind of diminishing returns
towards this just there is such a
ceiling that we might find that when we
make a being which is 10 smarter than us
on some scale It could only make a being
which is five percent smarter than it
and that being will make up machine make
it being which is only 2.5 percent
smarter than it and all this will kind
of asymptote to some
intelligence ceiling and I don't know
this turns on very subtle issues about
the structure of intelligence space I'm
rather
uh rather doubtful there is such an
intelligence ceiling or if there is one
maybe it's something like you know the
limits of computability compared to you
know hyper computation the infinite
system could do but I think that ceiling
is so high that there's room for an
awful lot of super intelligence before
uh before we get there but in any case I
would say that you know for the purposes
of say caution and thinking about the
future I would just turn the point back
on you and say that before that there is
such an intelligent ceiling is itself an
extremely speculative one I wouldn't
want to rely on this on this extremely
speculative thought to uh kind of
protect us from from the you know
potential risks of AGI in the future if
there's only a
20 chance there's not such a
intelligence ceiling then this is
something that we'd very much need to be
to be worrying about
yeah I mean fair enough it's certainly a
risk factor it's certainly something
that we need to uh need to keep a handle
on
well let me ask you about one specific
tying there so um I'm thinking you're
probably familiar with uh Carl friston
and you know his free energy principle
and he sends his regards by the way he
uh we talked to him a couple weeks back
and and uh he wanted to ask you about
kind of one line of thinking that he's
been exploring lately and I want to give
you a quote from his 2018 article and my
self-conscious or does self-organization
entail self-consciousness
and he said the proposal on offer here
is that the Mind comes into being when
self-evidencing has a temporal thickness
or counter factual death which grounds
inferences about the consequences of my
action
on this view Consciousness is nothing
more than the inference about my future
namely self-evidizing consequences of
what I could do
what do you think about that that
perspective
yeah I'd have to know more about the
connection to Consciousness I know that
yeah friston is very has developed very
deeply the idea of the Mind as a
prediction machine a mind which is
basically set up to you know predict
whatever signal is coming next
and that with that one basic tilos you
know predict what's next what's next
what's next then you get to build these
amazing models of the world with all of
these um
all of these are these capacities and
that's a really interesting
uh perspective for thinking about the
mind and intelligence in general and
it's got to be at least one huge part of
the story even if it's not the whole
story whole story as Kristen thinks it
is but I've never really understood the
distinct what this kind of predictive
approach has to say distinctively about
consciousness
you know because presumably there's a
whole lot of different predictive
processes and all kinds of levels of the
hierarchy including at the uh you know
very early vision and very late
cognition then the whole mind is engaged
in coming up with these predictions but
only some limited part of it is uh is
conscious what you just said about yeah
trying to figure out the predictions
consequent on our actions sounds to me
like a very general statement of
what the predictive approach says about
the mind in general and I haven't yet
heard what is the part that corresponds
to Consciousness why for example or some
representations get to be conscious
where so much of it in the brain is not
I can give you I can give you a bit more
detail which may be helpful because we
did dig into them with a on a bid and he
said um for one thing he he expected
that perhaps part of your response might
might entail or talk about the meta hard
problem you know why is it that certain
beings I.E things like philosophers and
people like you and me puzzle so much
about our qualitative experience and the
argument he makes there he says that if
we are inference machines that are built
to actively self-evidence then that
necessarily entails we need to have a
generative model about our experienced
world and if we have that that
generative model about our experience
World our experience world then we have
to entertain the hypothesis that we are
things having a qualitative experience
along with the alternate to that
hypothesis which is that we're not
having qualitative experiences and so
essentially that the capability to model
the world generatively really requires
that we entertain this hypothesis that
we're actually having qualitative
experiences or maybe not and that's why
we pontificate about it yeah it's
interesting I think the meta problem is
a yeah as a promising approach here so
the meta problem is you're why do we say
and think the things we do about
Consciousness instead of explaining
Consciousness directly let's explain uh
you know our internal model of of
Consciousness and yeah there's got to be
such a model so I think this is a
promising approach to take I still don't
fully I mean I think if you take the
predictive approach though what you
would expect is is the system would have
many different models you know a big
complex model of the world at all levels
it doesn't just correspond to
experienced reality but the models of
the World Way Beyond
what's experienced it would also you'd
also expect
um the model to have a model of the mind
to have a model of ourselves and our
relation to the world but what actually
happens in the in the human mind is we
have um
we have models at all levels you know
there's like so many different levels of
say of representation even in the visual
hierarchy
um and somehow though only one of those
levels seems to correspond to
Consciousness the question is why now do
we need a distinctive model of those
representations
in us which correspond to conscious
experience one idea I think one idea I
quite like is that this could be like a
simplification in fact we have millions
of layers of representation of the world
but to build all that into our model of
ourselves and our relation of the world
is going to be too complex so we
basically uh we oversimplify by saying
ah there's this one special relationship
we have to the world we call it
Consciousness or experience and you know
we experience certain things and then we
use them to reason about them and this
is massively oversimplified as a model
of the Mind
but it could be that uh that that
simplification
is then what actually gives us the sense
that we have this special thing called
Consciousness at least maybe that could
explain why it seems to us that we have
some special representations of the
world it's a further question why
those conscious representations should
seem to be so ineffable and subjective
and hard to explain and what and what
Carl has written about this
I think he and Andy Clark had some ideas
about the meta problem to try and push
on this maybe that maybe there'll be
certain representations that we'd have
to be especially certain that we have
them maybe that would give rise to
that you know Descartes idea that well
I'm not sure about the world but I know
that I'm I know that I'm thinking
I think therefore I am and they had some
kind of story about how this could get
the whole I think therefore I am
certainty in one's own mind going anyway
I think it's a it's an interesting
approach and I'm be very cool to see if
they can develop it further
fascinating I wanted to dig into this
modeling thing I was even thinking a
second ago when you were talking about
intelligence that straight away you
um did the hutter thing and we're
talking about agents performing in
environments and so on and even that is
a model and of course we're talking
about complex phenomena and the way we
model things depends on the level of
analysis but I'm really fascinated by
this idea that some phenomena is so
complex that it cannot be formalized or
communicated right almost as if there's
a representation problem now you
discussed in your Consciousness book
whether Consciousness itself could be
reductively explained and your knowledge
argument you spoke of this
neuroscientist Mary that had been
brought up in a black and white room
she's never seen any colors except for
black and white and Shades of Gray she's
nevertheless one of the world's leading
neuroscientists specializing in
neurophysiology of color vision she
knows everything there is to know about
neural processes involved in visual
information processing about the physics
of optical processes about the physical
makeup of objects in the environment but
she doesn't know what it's like to see
red no amount of reasoning from physical
facts alone will give her this knowledge
physical facts about systems do not tell
us what their conscious experiences are
like now you're speaking about this
phenomenon in respect of the conscious
or the phenomenological experience but I
think it's a much bigger problem of
representation with any complex system
right so what I find fascinating is that
all of us have a conscious experience
but it's completely ineffable as you
just said it's impossible for us to
communicate it to others and whenever we
try to do so we're reaching right just
like the Blind Men and the Elephant we
end up defining some weird abstract
Motif right chopping off 90 of the truth
the thing that fascinates me is that we
need to have some kind of formalism or
reduction in order to communicate uh you
know in order to know or even understand
anything but so often is the case that
all of the nuance and richness of the
phenomena is lost in doing so so I
suspect that any formalism of a complex
system might blind us from discovering a
much better and richer formalism later
because it kind of frames our thinking
in quite a pernicious way
um in your book so as I said you were
trying to separate rate the
phenomenological experience as something
that couldn't be described
um but do you think it could be extended
to any complex system
well we don't
as far as we know you know some complex
systems actually have conscious
subjective experience but you know most
of them don't uh you know this Mac on my
uh
um that I'm using right now is a very
complex system but not much reason to
think that it's uh conscious despite the
complexity of what's going on within it
so certain kinds of complexity go along
with Consciousness but if we were to
kind of return to that matter problem
approach for a moment maybe there are
certain kinds of properties
of a complex system that tend to produce
reports for example that the system is
conscious so maybe
maybe some complex systems have the
capacity for a certain kind of direct
self-modeling that correspondence to you
and what we think of as introspection we
have introspection which is a way of
saying this is what I'm perceiving right
now this is what I'm thinking right now
this is what I'm feeling
right now and we build a model of
ourselves and it may well be that that
model is highly oversimplified you don't
have access to all these facts about
ourselves so perhaps you could tell a
story where the kinds of complex systems
that give rise at least to this capacity
for introspection are then at least
going to report themselves as being
as being conscious and maybe that could
get at some element maybe of this or the
ineffability of of Consciousness you'd
expect to build these very
simplified self models we wouldn't know
immediately how to extend
to other people I mean I still think
in principle you if you you could take
Mary who knows all about the human brain
and she could come to know all about
those models in uh in other people
um but it still seems if she's never
actually experienced red for herself
there's still something really crucial
about this objective experience that she
doesn't know she doesn't know what it's
like to experience red and knowing all
about the details of the model still
hasn't told her told her that so I think
that's still something that needs
explaining some people at this point
just say uh that sense of something
extra is an illusion
um something extra that the model hasn't
explained is an illusion but that's
really where a lot of the action is at
then
just just quickly do you think there
could be a sense of something extra to
intelligence as well as consciousness
hmm
probably yeah we model our own
intelligence with some massively
oversimplified self models that were
programmed into us by Nature
um the model S has these agents with
Incredible capacities free will
uh rationality reason it probably
um again it will
yeah maybe I talked about
consciousnesses involving the subjective
elements intelligence as involving the
objective elements but yeah we probably
have oversimplified models of those
conscious
of those of those behavioral elements as
well perhaps that make us out to be more
rational or more free
or more capable than we uh than we
actually are
I I wanted to ask um what is an
interesting simulation is is our
universe interesting or not right
because we represent just a pinprick of
intelligence so should intelligence be
more spread out in the eyes of the
simulator
um or in the vast majority of instances
would there just be gas everywhere or a
singularity maybe stars can't form uh
you know maybe the interesting phenomena
itself is on the um you know kind of
boundary uh between Chaos and Order uh
or between order and disorder I should
say which is just a tiny sliver so what
do you think makes an interesting
simulation I don't know I think it
probably you know depends on your
perspective and it might for example
depend on the perspective of the
simulators what they're what they're
after you know one thing that a
simulator might be doing is just create
a whole lot of different universes with
different potential say laws of physics
that they're simulating just to see what
happens and maybe
and if they're interested in saying life
or intelligence then it could be that
they're going to find that okay well 99
of these simulations don't produce
anything like life or intelligence and
yeah one percent of them produce life
and point zero one percent lead to uh
lead to intelligence so if that's what
they're interested in
in studying
fantastic but they might be interested
in who's to say you know the laws of
physics or Galaxy formation more
generally totally independent of life
and intelligence so I don't think
there's any single standard of what's uh
of what's interesting I mean to me as a
philosopher interested in Consciousness
I'm especially interested in this
question of What kinds of simulations
might actually develop
conscious beings within them
um not least because that's going to be
especially relevant to our situation if
we're in a simulation it seems we're
conscious so um there's a question about
uh about it just how this kind of
simulation might get set up but I think
this whole I mean already simulations
are used
in actual practice for you know a
million different purposes by scientists
studying this phenomenon or that
phenomenon by people doing entertainment
by people doing prediction of the future
by people doing simulation of the past
and I guess when it comes to simulated
universes all of those all of those
sources of Interest May themselves be
present